les vacances d'été ne sont pas synonyme
d'arrêt de la vaccination dans les
yvelines avec environ 50 % de sa
population primo vacciner et dans la
crainte d'une nouvelle vague liés aux
variants delta des mesures ont été
prises pour permettre la vaccination du
plus grand nombre
tout d'abord le délai entre deux
injections qui était de 42 jours a été
assouplie il est dorénavant situés sur
une fourchette de 21 à 49 jours les
plages d'ouverture des centres de
vaccination ont été une fois de plus
étendu et il n'est plus nécessaire de
prendre rendez vous au préalable
ensuite bien que trois centres et choisi
de fermer définitivement d'ici fin
juillet à chatou rambouillet et
bonnières-sur-seine 413 ouvert tout
l'été ils sont situés au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines au centre
commercial de vélizy 2 à saint germain
en laye et à mantes la jolie
des opérations ponctuelles seront
également organisées tout au long de
l'été
chronologiquement cela commencera par le
11 juillet à la phase 2 de trappes pour
la finale de l'euro de football
suivront les 16 et 17 juillet dans la
base de loisirs de verneuil sur seine et
sur les aires d'autoroute de
morainvilliers les 23 et 24 juillet
entre le 30 juillet et le 4 septembre
une opération au coeur des quartiers des
mureaux aura lieu et enfin du 24 au 26
août aux différents centres sociaux de
carrières sous poissy